you don't even have to take it out of
the box man we know what he looks like
no i'm good man i know what you're doing
that's good let's go josh let's go
without the knife let's go joe just whip
out the next more importantly though how
much did you guys spend at a stop i
spent because you won't actually believe
this because i
this was completely coincidental i
literally spent 500 exact really yeah
look i spent 500 holy [ __ ] i spent
dollars
okay and how much did you spend connor
well i'm just getting my gorgeou
that's it
wait he doesn't have a stand no he like
goes on the side of a table
oh yeah i actually see the box it says
noodle stopper figure what does that
mean that means you put it on top of
your noodles
okay
um so i spent a total of
six hundred and twenty dollars oh damn
well before we move on from a stop
though i wanna hear the story about what
the [ __ ] you went through in a stop oh
i lie i forgot a figure oh never mind
and it's my coolest and most expensive
oh okay
uh do you want to carry on with that
thing though or no no no go show you
show your show
close your eyes boys
i'm gonna i want to unbox it fully
before i show you
i think i know what it is yeah it's the
[ __ ] most coolest figure yeah it's
the one that we all saw last year as
well was it there last year
is it from that one series i haven't
seen yet no no no no no no no no no no
no
perhaps a certain no
shunt i i have no idea what the [ __ ]
you're talking about i'm serious bro
you're gonna be i i saw him pick this
out so yeah but you did yeah i saw you
picture well you just have spoilers joey
yeah so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
open my eyes because i don't know what
it is
[Music]
it looks so dumb outside of the box
opening my eyes at all
this is one of the dumbest and yet
coolest figures i've ever seen it's the
most epic figure yeah [ __ ] time if i
can get it open sorry god
god really uh
really uh dragging this out corner
[Laughter]
that's amazing
where did you finally see this i didn't
see it it was there last year as well it
was 300 yeah
i'd say worth it honestly this is so
sweet
in which box would that fit in how did
they display that it was it's literally
like
[Laughter]
okay that's the box it comes in
i love i love this scene in hunter
hunter and i just when i saw it and i
knew i had the spare budget i couldn't i
couldn't say no the only reason why i
didn't buy this last year is because it
was over our budget yeah yeah it's so
sick yeah i actually wish i could like
fence
longer
i actually wish i bought more in a stop
because there were like more cool
figures that i wanted to buy but
like i didn't know how much i would be
spending in like the next ones yeah yeah
um but looking back um i wish i there
were so many figures that i wish i had
bought there were like some black lagoon
figures and some gaps
yeah the gowns figure i really wish i
had bought yeah yeah the gangster was
actually so hot yeah but i mean i'm but
i mean like a stop's a cool store um so
is lashing band there were so many cool
figures in lashes they're in the same
building as well yeah exactly
careful this was 160 dollars
is that the most expensive figure oh no
this is mostly this is the three hundred
dollars yeah this is
close to four it's like the flimsiest
plastic thing ever but yeah i imagine it
i imagine it's just that much because of
how pretty rare it is yeah i do i mean
i've never seen that before i've never
seen that i don't know where you even
buy it or where you get it from i i it
must have been available quite a while
probably a collective collector's item
it's it's just the coolest thing i've
ever seen it's so ridiculous
[Music]
yeah this this has a different center of
gravity
honestly it does
it's very top-heavy
a little bit make sure you kind of feel
like how dumb it would look in real life
if you sure gone when he was going super
saiyan all top
but yeah that was my uh this is my haul
at http
yeah i mean you mostly all of it was
this oh yeah mostly it was jojo figures
yeah mostly it's three dios and a
gauntlet yeah so four jojo figures uh
black baller black butler and uh
it's pretty good oh can it be black goku
all of these can beat the goku black i
think that's still my favorite
[Laughter]
that's your favorite when we have this
joey how dare you how dare you love
because the thing is i saw this one last
year i just can't believe this one's
real
and it like unironically looks epic as
well
i can't get over how cool that looks
could you repeat that
we can't show that
i mean so we found a meme recently which
is just like um like ultrasound
goku with the caption could you repeat
that and it's like you can see his dick
just half chopped off it's it's it's
like the edge of his [ __ ]
on the screen it's not the funniest
thing i've ever seen in my life all
right was uh that was that was a stop
moving on i need the toilet so before we
move on to amiami though um joey what
was this thing about this guy buying
kirito figures that i've heard about oh
yeah yeah yeah so when i was lining up
at a stop there was a dude in front of
me it's in my video as well right but
there was a dude in front of me in like
a full-on business so it was like a
proper japanese salary man and uh i
overheard
and i thought i thought i doubted myself
for a second i overheard the words
kirito
and 600 000 yen i thought
which is six thousand dollars six
thousand dollars
and i was like excuse me
that that can't be right did you get a
glimpse i leaned in closer no i think he
ordered it in bulk at asoc because i
think there was just too many and then i
found out as i was you know he left and
as i was checking out and you know i
talked to the dude i was like so uh the
guy the guy before me
what what did he buy if you don't mind
me asking and he said oh he bought six
thousand dollars worth of curator
figures
they do exist and i was like oh my god
they actually exist
these types of waves exist so he
literally went into the store and said
i'll take your entire take your entire
stomach off the kirito figures who's
buying six thousand dollars worth of
kirito foreigners he was probably like
in his maybe mid 30s right
just buying like i think he bought like
13 or 14 kirito figures like so many
that he didn't even like bother bringing
them up he i think he just gave them the
paper and said just send it to me
oh my dropped his money and they just
left is this like an investment is is is
he like is this
like a kirito reseller
that's the only explanation i have for
this guy it was insane
you know i guess so